thank you for the introduction and
thanks to all of the organizers for
inviting me and also for letting me stay
here for the whole winter term during
all the workshops it was quite
interesting so the work I'm going to
talk about today is more in the
phylogeny side of things so and it's the
work that I was doing with my PhD
student Mario the service so the
motivation for this is you know doing
phylogenies with different phenotypes so
you sort of imagine a finite number of
phenotypes that you're interested in
studying and trying to figure out a
phylogenetic tree on these on these
different types so you know you can
think of things like wingless and not
and winged insects or selfie compatible
instead of compatible plants so there is
some switching between between the the
phenotypes in the sense that you can
have a winged species that becomes wing
list and then becomes winged again so
essentially the way so people the
biologist or theoretical biologists who
have been investigating this run
branching processes with multiple types
and then sort of figure out the
phylogeny by running simulations and
trying to figure out you know if I'm if
if I'm in a certain type set at a
certain time what is the chance that
that will eventually give me this this
different distribution of species of the
tips and my you know this is all very
well and I think some of the simulation
software that is around like busy that
fits John and I don't have and classy
Brett Goldberg gig is developed they run
very nicely
I was curious what one can say
mathematically about phylogenetic trees
on different types and whether you know
maybe that can be helpful for some of
the quantitative biology analysis so
what I'm going to start with is a
branching process on different on with
multiple types so you should imagine so
for the first part well for most of the
talk i'm going to do discrete-time
branching processes and so we have a
setting of a galten Watson tree and then
you have an us a certain offspring
distribution and each parent has a
different different random variable each
type of parent has a different offspring
distribution with which it can give
offspring of different types so you know
in this sort of graphical representation
you have two types and you see that you
know each of the types can give
different number of offspring for for
its children for the further types ok so
what so let me just go back for a second
so here we have the full full tree full
genealogy of these things but of course
phylogenetic trees basically want to go
you know and just chop off all of the
leaves and say something about the trees
the reduced tree or the ancestral tree
that you get if you eliminate all of the
offspring that did not make it to some
present time so one of the ways that
we've we decided to look at this is
based on a coalescent point process
representation of phylogenetic trees
that I'm going to first described in a
single type setting which was an idea
that I'm really sort of introduced to me
and then we sort of wrote some results
about about the distribution of the
phylogeny based on this point parts this
representation so to to explain this
essentially you know
you you embed the full tree in a plane
and in such a way that things don't
overlap so you're sort of putting it on
a grid and and essentially you look for
the first individual at the present time
in the present population and there's
some sort of spine that goes down
genealogical spine that goes down from
it and then you look at all the all the
other present individuals as to where
how they're related to the individual
before it so in some sense it's not a
coalescent picture that goes I have a
certain number of types here and then
I'm coalescing down so I have events in
time that you know you're learning a
Markov process backwards in time that
way sort of horizontally but you're
writing vertically here you're running
things horizontally you're going to have
a certain kind of construction that sort
of runs horizontally which means you're
including more and more of the present
individuals in building your tree so so
what what you have here is you're trying
to stick on the the genealogy of the
individuals one by one so the individual
to then the individual three and once
you get to this is what my computer does
so you're slowly attaching edges I'll
come back so I need to touch it often
enough I guess so you're you're building
on the genealogy of the individuals that
are present at a certain time and you
see that you know when you do that you
will avoid all the leaves that you have
in the process so the quantities that
you you are interested in if you're if
you're building a phylogeny is
essentially the depth at which you
attach the different types so if you
think about you know this quantity AI
that's the coalescent time so
between when I have individual to it's
called lesson time where the previous
individual is only one depth if I have
individual six that it's called lesson
time where the individual one is way
down here and then seven is going to
have a coalescent time next 60 in this
in this way so this step then three has
the same depth then 4 has this depth
with 35 has a short depth with 46 has a
very deep depth with five you're slowly
building exactly the kind of points that
will give you a phylogenetic tree that
you can then reconstruct the same way
that you would if you just got points
from which one came first in a
coalescent point process going
vertically downwards so the the kind of
ingredients that you have to keep track
of is essentially at each point you need
to in this picture you need to keep
track of if this individual which one do
I want to pick this individual here has
three offspring how many of those will
have any descendants surviving to the
present time and in addition okay so for
instance this one has three but by the
time you come to the individual three
only one of them is left okay so because
of multiple offspring in in the
branching process you tell myself what
will happen then I don't follow my
advice so you not because of multiple
offspring numbers you not only have to
know how many of them will have
descendants in the future but you also
have to know how many you've already
seen so in a sense because you're going
horizontally you have to keep track of
you sort of have to keep reducing the
number of offspring that will have
descendants as you as you move along or
is it where the horse would use adding
one of the time
so so essentially you know you sort of
put random variables I keep touching
that and thinking them so hope if you go
in the in this picture you can
essentially tack them all along the
spine first I mean it depends how you
want to construct this can tack these on
and then figure out if you're doing a
construction you can figure out how many
of these this guy is going to have and
then you proceed to the next one and
then you put them on and then for
instance this guy had only two that are
going to make it up right so it only has
one other descendant it's going to make
it up and then here you sort of get
independent branching events because you
have a spine that you now are free to
choose new you know how many offspring
you have here I'm confusing okay look
let's see if it gets better should have
let her explain this part and so if you
keep track of these quantities then
essentially you can build this process
you can show that this is a markov chain
horizontally and this process so not the
process of just the depths but the
process where you're keeping track of
how many descendants you still haven't
seen its how many offspring you still
that have descendants in the future you
still haven't seen so that does the
Markovian property and then from that so
that that's this process di an and then
the the coalescing depths are simple
function of that because you're just
looking at you know the first time were
you know the first with the first dip
here that where the there's you know
there's only there's there's nothing
here
alright so this this sort of explains
this in a sort of more sparse picture so
that you can see it so you build the
individuals going down with the the
number of offspring that will have some
descendants and then as you're exploring
this process you keep eliminating the
ones that you've already seen and
essentially that will allow you then to
reconstruct the whole by launching
alright so the result that we had in our
paper was that essentially you can write
this process down as a Markov chain and
the transitions are such that everything
so you start with a first you start with
a you you start with the first
individual you you are free to sort of
independently put the offspring down
with a certain distribution that is
using the fact that all those
individuals at the different times will
have descendants in the future so that's
why you have this conditioning over here
and then as you proceed the next
individual you you know you look for its
depth right and then for that individual
anything below its depth you have to
keep the same as the previous individual
because that's part of the spine cell
and anything above your your coalescence
time you can now tack on to this so for
instance in this picture you know once
you you see that this is your collection
time for the individual six you have to
keep all of this stuff intact so all
this part of your of your sequence you
have to keep in your process but this
part you're allowed to build from new
random variables because this portion
the sort of subtree is independent of
what has happened here
you walk us through one step of the
Markov chain like you like was in the
going from i to i plus i guess it's not
once definitely markup chamber sure so
um okay so just make sure this isn't
moving yeah i can probably do in here so
the the markov chain is each each time
or so time is not time but its
individual abled by the individuals at
the present time right that's your what
would usually be thought of as time in a
markov chain right so this is your first
and then you and so this is your first
element and it has a sequence it's a
sequence valued point right so and the
sequence consists of how many
individuals this this answers ancestor
have so how many offspring does it have
that will make it to the present day and
it did this depth as well so this one
has this one has to in addition to this
by this one has one in addition to the
spine these ones have 0 0 0 0 and this
one has one right so this this the first
element of the chain would be to 1000
one okay and then the next one has the
shifted first point you know and then
this stays the same all these depths
that stay the same but here there's no
no room to add new stuff because you're
in discrete time but here for instance
all of this stays the same so d6 has all
of the this part the same as SSD one but
then here it has new ingredients so it
has one at this level 0 2 in this level
0 0 0 okay so you think of it as a
sequence of natural numbers at each
point at each step of the trick we join
you
sequence or speech and its own
independent Markov chain no it's not you
need to think of it as a sequence right
it's the depth is not by itself giving
you anything you have to keep track of
that you think of it as a spine think of
think of each one of these things being
is fine and then I'm kind of changing
the shape of the spine in some Markovian
wet so you think of it as a markov chain
on spines but on the spine I'm only
going to record values at these branch
points does that make sense so you have
to the spine is evolving in a Markovian
way not like you can't just look at
levels ok so what happens now if I want
to do this in a multiple typesetting
well because the offspring distribution
depends on the parent type I'm obviously
going to have to record not just the
number of offspring but I'm going to
have to record what type that ancestor
is and what type the offspring work so
now I go back into this picture and I
just sort of enlarge the state space of
my you know spine of my mark of saying
and the way i enlarged it is at every
point this di as opposed to being just a
natural number at each depth n this di
is now a sequence of types ok so now at
this point before I had you know I said
you know this guy has everything the
same is here but here it's allowed to
just put and I had some numbers right
here it had one and here it has zeros
here it had two and here 0 etc now here
I have tight a sequence of type so
instead of coding just 1 i'm coding a
vector of types so as they go down if
it's zero will let them you know that's
a 90 set 90 set here but here i have to
encode these sites ok so i have a vector
pipes at each point of what are my
people one of my what are my types of my
offsprings that are going to have this
in the future okay and so because of the
whole sort of you know the Markovian
property doesn't change in terms of the
tree structure if you keep record of the
types so that whole aspect of why you
still again get a Markov chain still
holds if you just enlarge the state
space this way so that part of the sort
of proof is relatively straightforward
and probably perfect for PhD students to
do hopefully I wasn't you know cruel by
making her do all of imitation but
essentially again you can show that you
have a Markov chain in which you can
construct things where again you know
everything below so AI is the depth at
which you're attaching to your previous
existing the sign of the existent
individual and so below that you have to
keep your chain at that level you again
you shifts the number of types right
like you erase the first one because
you've seen that one so you're just
keeping these are this is just a shift
by 1 this way so you drop the first guy
right as I said you record the vector of
types now you just drop the first guy
and you shift everybody white by one and
then above it so this is kind of written
funny work and it's going downwards but
for for all the depths above now I get
to pick again from some I get to pick
independent variables except here before
I was allowed to pick independent
variables right in in the in the single
type setting I was allowed to just pick
you know independent variables in each
one of these points here I can't really
do that what what I have to do is take a
whole spine at once because you know how
many things that have here depends on
what type they are and I don't know what
type there unless I know you know what
what its parent was doing so at this
point essentially I you know everything
here stays the same this guy gets you
know this guy gets eliminated so I
I remain with this vector well this
guy's is not there because he doesn't
have to send so i have two things so
i've eliminated this guy i stay with
just one point but here then i get to
tack along all of them i have to you
know encode all of the individuals are
the types of these originals along the
spine so if you you know use that
distribution as this ADA here that I've
encoded then you again have this Markov
chain in which you can build this
phylogenetic tree so so maybe this will
illustrate how it's going so say you go
for you take first to spine and then you
build you know the the gray shaded guys
are the ones who are not going to have
individuals that make it and then the
dark shaded guys are the ones who are so
at this point you know I've built up the
two and three parts and then you know to
start off with the guy who's going to
make it you know then I've built up to
four or five and so when I'm building
six I have to choose you know I know
which offspring this guy is going to
have because of my earlier construction
along the school's fine so I know the
type of this guy so now I can sample
from this distribution I can make some
of them you know from the usual
offspring distribution of a parent of
the stipe I kill some of them because
they're not going to make it to I you
know I killed them independently based
on the probability of making it to this
time and then the ones that make it you
start by you know you build the spine of
this guy and then you'll eventually get
to later on building the spine based on
the other guys so that's what this does
all right so what what kind of features
can you extract from this tree all right
so one of the things that you know you
can you are interested in when you're
when when you have a phylogenetic tree
is the
distribution of edge lengths for
instance industry because it sort of
tells you something about the shape of
the tree so you can from this
construction you can extract the first
the the you know you can extract
obviously the depths of all the
consecutive individuals right that's
just comes from how the tree was built
now I might be interested because I have
multiple types now there's sort of extra
features in the tree that I might be
interested in such as how deep are the
coalescence times of individuals that
are the same type so you know here okay
these three are all the same type so
they you know I'm just using the real
you know call us since I'm here but then
the next time the next guy of the same
type is all the way here and so I may be
interested in how long then till I link
up to us this side and then the next guy
of that type is all the way here so I
wouldn't have to extract this length to
figure it so as you can see not the the
same type coalescence coalescence points
are not necessarily filling up the set
of all coalescence points because you
have this intersperse ille of
individuals so this call s in time is
now going to appear anywhere in the same
type stuff because it doesn't appear as
a question time of this guy and this guy
and it doesn't appear as a question time
of that guy in that guy so some of the
points they are just sort of you know so
that the coalescence points of same type
individuals are subset of the of the
full course access or what yep next
means
this painting is so what sort of kind of
biological you know this significance
does that have right you haven't sort of
like coconut I don't have an answer I
don't like not yeah I so yeah this all
depends on the embedding of things in
them so the next may mean nothing in
terms of ouch unless for some reason you
so you can write down formula that
describe based on the offspring
distribution you can read their formula
that tell you what what is the
distribution of this is just a
consecutive individuals and this is of
the coalescent the distribution of
course and science for a specific type l
ok and it's you know it's a messy
formula that isn't particularly pleasant
because well you're just using the
generating function of the offspring
distribution however now we come to a
special case that's particularly nice to
analyze so in the single type setting
you know if you have a geometric
offspring distribution then you have a
lot of nice features of the phylogenetic
tree because you have a lot of
Independence properties so sort of the
analogous thing for that in a multi
typesetting are multi type linear
fractional offspring distribution okay
so in a single type setting you would
have again it's it fits it is a linear
fractional distribution but here it's
just extended to multiple types and it
has this you know the reason why it's
particularly nice is that the offspring
essentially somehow the dependence of
the parent type is seen kind of only in
the first offspring or a one offspring
which you sort of place as first in this
embedding and then the rest are are not
tight not parent type dependent okay so
there's there's a lot of memory lists
gets built in to just this offspring
distribution but it's not completely
useless as you'll see some I mean it's
not so it still has them up some it
retains some multi type features in it
so this is sort of just what the
generating function of a multi type
distribution would be and the results
that were obtained before is that
essentially if you have that kind of
offspring distribution then it it the
distribution of the offspring at that
are in the engine also has that same
form so where the where the parameters
are given by some you know matrix
iterations from the original so you know
a lot about what what the types of
individuals a generation n will be if
you have such a nice office for
distribution so in that case I guess it
it's it's not that surprising but it's
not immediately obvious that now your
coalescence times end up somehow
completely forgetting about the type of
the parent so you can show that in that
picture you know the lesson times of
consecutive things are completely
independent of what the what the
individual at that depth what it's type
was so you get very simple formulas they
you know with with a single parameter
that you computed using that matrix
iteration and you know the same thing
holds obviously for coalescence times of
same type individuals except it just you
know
you just depend on which is the type of
individual you're looking for same its
next its next existent species I mean
type in in in the current distribution
so essentially you you know in the
multitec linear fractional setting you
have a very nice structure because this
is no longer a complicated Markov chain
it's just a sequence of independent
identically distributed random variables
because you go along the linear
fractional case does it to behave in a
special way or is it just you can
analyze it it behaves in a special way I
mean we thinking what the physical
properties on my open very special yeah
we're here they can't even compose these
jittery comments with themselves you
stay in the same okay let me put it this
way if you look at the single
typesetting you know yes the geometric
offspring distribution is special but in
the you know in the rescale limit you
know it's just it gives you yet it gives
you the same tree as a lot of the other
distribution I don't think that's the
case here i know i think this the multi
type one is a little more special than
that
however so suppose now you know so you
think okay do I still see features of
this offspring distribution in my in in
the shape of my tree or in the
statistics of these coalescing times and
you can you know the the simplest thing
that we look that is ok let's look at
the offspring distribution of two types
we're in one case you have a very
symmetric type of relationship between
the two types so the Austrian resolution
is actually you retain you you give
individuals of the same type as yourself
with probability P and you give
individuals as of the other type of
probability 1 minus B but it's the same
for both parents okay and the other one
is the asymmetric case where you sort of
feel like okay I can go from wing to
english but i cannot get my wing back
afterwards so you have no chance of you
know giving if your if your type to you
have no chance of giving an offspring of
type 1 okay and it's very you know if
you if you look at what you get then in
the tree essentially you can show
there's a there's a sort of a you know
there's a stochastic dominance of the
distribution of Kalessin types in the
asymmetric case versus its retro case
because so the guise of type 2 which
only gave their own type are going to
have shorter coalescence times for the
same the same type coalescence times
then the guys in the asymmetric case
because essentially they create only sub
trees of their own type okay whereas
it's the other way around for the type 1
so you can you can sort of show that you
have complete you know stochastic a city
you have asymmetry in the distribution
of the pearlescent science as well okay
and of course if you just look at the
symmetric distribution and you look at
what was that chance of switching to the
other type if it's bigger than a half
then again you can show that the that
the depths of the we're the ones connect
is going to be greater than where the
where the two is connect because you
have a higher chance of switching oh
sorry so here is also if you have more
of type ones okay so you can sort of do
all sorts of things like this and that's
nice but here's you know what this
generates is so you start with some
branching process you know the offspring
or you assume some offspring
distribution and so then you know this
kind of coalescing process allows you to
simulate these trees or to describe the
distribution or some features of the
street but you know I I wanted to see is
there something you know is is there
some way of sort of going back right so
inferring from let's say knowing what
the tree looks like can you now or at
least what's that something about the
the current state situation or very
recent state very recent situation let's
say a couple of generations back can
universe something about which is the
branching process which is the ranching
mechanism that gave rise to this tree
okay so in the single type setting you
sort of well you know they're there
aren't even good ways of describing
shapes trees but if you assume things
are neutral then essentially any kind of
ranching process that you put down and
is in that's critical will when you
prune stuff the shape modulo the branch
lengths will look like a Yule tree so by
shape here I mean forget about how long
exactly the branches are just keep the
actual shape so that's sort of your
prototype phylogeny in a single type
case so which you will get if you've
just had a birth-death process so now if
I have a multi type something like a
multi type birth and death process and I
start you know now I mean continue sign
I have a too-tight birth and death
process if I start pruning away all the
individuals in the genealogy that did
make
today I will end up with something
that's distributed as a multi type Yule
tree so you'll trees is the genealogy of
a pure birth process so the multi type
your birth process would be one where
you know I at some rate I give offspring
different rates for different types of
parents and different types of offspring
but I also can switch to another type
along my lineage in continuous time and
that's because essentially I may have
given birth so I was of a certain type
but I gave birth to another type I
didn't make it to the top but the other
type did so that's sort of the event in
the tree that you would see is switching
color so you have not just in the single
type you just had pure births right here
you have births and of different rates
for different types but you also have a
switch of color along the tree so switch
or type along just one lineage and so
what are the features so so if you look
at the present day stock what are the
things that can maybe retain some of the
information about these rates of
switching and the rates of giving birth
to different types things like the leaf
configuration or or the pendant
configuration are sorry so the leaf
configuration tells you how many
different types you have that the tips
but the cluster configuration kind of
should retain some information because
that's you know that's sort of the last
coalescent time event in the past and
that will tell you sort of the the
chance that you will have had children
of a certain time so what we looked at
is trying to figure out results on the
number of cherries so in the to type
setting we didn't 4k types with the
pictures illustrate we have many
cherries of different types you have
many pendants and different types so
pendant is just a leaf that has a single
edge going back where the cherries one
that coalesce is with another leaf one
generation back so if you look at
you can write a simple set of equations
for the mean number of you need to
retain the mean number of leaves overall
since you're in continuous time you need
to retain the mean number cherries of
the different types and the mean number
of pendants of different types you can
write this set of equations and then you
know what I wanted to to look at it can
you now infer back what the rates are if
you know these amounts now at a fixed
time that's a little tricky if you
assume time is very large so you've
taken in these equations you've taken a
limit as T goes to infinity you're in
some kind of stationarity then you can
revert the set of equations back so that
based on knowing how many what's the
proportion of the different type of
cherries and what's the proportion of
the different type of pendants you can
recover the rates of the of the multi
teal tree so the pendants in the
cherries is just going one generation in
fact yeah yeah so that's why it's very
easy to write a recursion of what
happens in the next this so the set of
equations you can write for K types and
you can write I mean it's just a Messier
matrix right because now you have you
know you have cake squares number of
different type offend ins and you have k
times k plus 1 over 2 different chairs
so you just are holding bigger matrices
but the results hold and you can do it
in the fact that you can have the rates
be time dependent what we the results
below that you can turn back is not for
timed event so virtual at this point
right you're keeping the rates always
constant in time which is not what you
would have in if you took the phylogeny
other birth-death process
your problem your your probability of
making it to some time later is time
dependent right but for now the result
is oh I paid you to student hasn't
graduated yet so there's there's some
hope yeah this result is for a time
independent branch and rates in them no
yeah Cherry's impendence you have enough
essentially if you look at the number of
parameters in the number of quantities
they match okay and this is where I
finish my talk and thank you for your
attention so you see that mathematically
you have a
versity properties sufficient no
distractions yeah
exactly the gardener's yeah but it is
they are away when T is fixed and you
don't know the fractions is there a
statistical
with these feats and you don't have to
do just one trillion yeah I don't know I
don't know hi yeah it's just your
research yeah i mean i don't know
because we have thought about it that
one but essentially what you have is
sort of expectations rather on the
widely good yeah yeah we started first
from you're doing expected means yeah if
anyone knows of results in multi type
trees I'd be happy to hear about it
because the google scholar is not
helping you know when you look into
something and I used to see similar
properties and in a regular markov
change that you basically know how did
you actually need to go in time to
figure out your rice haven't thought
about a good question I haven't thought
about capital I mean here we're just
doing things based on the maximum work
boy but yeah I you know she's working as
we stood maybe what I don't know
personally I we had a daughter
prohibition talk
it's not much time coldest morning
speakers